salut la dernière trou story est sorti
le 13 février 2018 donc à plus d'un an
aujourd'hui il ya une raison à ça parce
qu'à chaque fois je mets des quotas de
light afin de faire la prochaine true
stories for pire n'est pas trop souvent
du coup il y en a une par an ça va c'est
aussi parce que je mets un filtre
naturel à la récurrence de ce format
l'avant-dernière j'habite cac 40 mais
pousse bleus genre d 1h40 en effet une
hausse la dernière j'ai dit à 10% de la
communauté toujours donc c'était à 70000
pouces bleus c'est à 72 milles au moment
où je vous parle donc la prochaine ce
sera quand celle ci sera cent mille
pouces on n'est pas prêt de la voir
aujourd'hui j'ai donc vous raconter le
jour où j'ai tout perdu ça remonte à
huit ans vous allez avoir les détails de
tout ça le pourquoi du comment
quand je dis tous et tous en toute ma
vie entière perdu enfin sauf moi mais le
plus important si avant de rentrer dans
les détails je vous remercie d'avoir
soutenu à ce point la vidéo cluedo qui
est sorti mercredi dernier un peu d'eau
géants dans la vraie vie si vous ne
l'avez pas vu vous pouvez juste cliquer
au dessus de moi je veux la même
description c'est clairement le projet
de dinguerie de la chaîne que j'ai pu
réaliser avec carcross mxm émis ltr doc
cévennes et céline h
allez voir ça si vous êtes passé à côté
et si vous l'avez vu j'espère que vous
me suivez sur instagram d'ailleurs il
n'est pas trop tard si c'est pas le cas
mon instagram est ici parce que je vous
ai partagé plein de bonus qu'on n'a pas
mis dans la vidéo en story installé puis
aussi en dur bref suivez moi sur
instagram c'est beaucoup plus simple
rejoignez les 150000 que nous sommes
la vidéo que vous allez voir a été
tourné dans un théâtre avec vous les
abonnés en public parce que j'ai loué un
titre qui s'appelle la nouvelle scène
pour faire plein de vidéos là bas avec
une centaine d'autres vous j'avais fait
de billetterie gratuit donc de temps en
temps vous allez voir des formats qui
ont été tournées là c'est le cas de
cette trou story
et puis j'avais aussi une facilité à
voir ce théâtre là puisque vous le savez
je fais mes spectacles théâtre depuis
2011 d'ailleurs les trois dernières
dates de la saison c'est quoi ces royan
le 5 juillet c'est lunel fin juillet et
c'est aussi le québec du 15 au 17 août
je suis à québec vous avez les
informations à description je viens pas
souvent c'est une petite salle intime de
100 places je fais trois représentations
les québécois il est vraiment temps de
réserver maintenant en fait et ça va
être beaucoup trop cool et puis je
verrai parcourir la france à partir de
septembre mais ça je vous en reparlerai
bientôt
est-ce que j'ai tout dis oui c'est tout
dit si ce n'est que je vous embrasse on
se reverra pas à la fin c'est pas la
peine donc leaké abonnez vous je vous
kiffe
à bientôt cha
je vais vous raconter le jour où j'ai
perdu toute ma vie à cause de douaniers
avant il ya quelques années je
travaillais environ dans 30 pays
différents par an ok je voyageais
beaucoup pour le travail c'était des
allers retours très court je faisais
soit des petites conférences sur le
mentaliste sur la mémoire ou des
démonstrations un peu comme on a fait là
je faisais ce genre de choses là et je
revenus vraiment posé en france en 2011
et et en 2000 2010 ou 2011
je ne sais plus l'année exacte je
travaillais au chili et après j'avais un
petit truc à faire au pérou et après je
prenais l'avion depuis lima pour rentrer
en france
et c'est là où on m'a volé mon ipad mon
macbook et mes disques durs externes
c'est à dire toute ma vie numérique a
été balayée et tout ce qui était de
l'ordre de la sauvegarde était déjà avec
moi et on me l'a pris en même temps je
vais à l'aéroport de lima
je suis un peu pressés par le temps mais
ça va tu vois je donne mon bagage pour
qu'il aille en soute
et puis je donne ma pièce d'identité mon
passeport et là y'a un douanier qui
arrivent et qui demandent à avoir mon
passeport il le feuillette
hélas cette époque peut se mettre à la
place du douanier il voit que je suis
allé au qatar deux jours puis en norvège
3 jours puis au chili quatre jours il
fait aujourd hui fait des trucs bizarres
et donc c'est souvent je me faisais
contrôler j'ai l'habitude de ça donc il
me dit on va faire en valais dans la
petite salle pour faire la fouille
intégrale des intégrales de ma valise
ma dignité préserver et donc il récupère
le bagage qui était parti pour aller en
dessous tu es mon bagage à main et c'est
parti et moi je sais comment ça se passe
avec eux faut pas faire le mariole si tu
veux que ça aille vite faut être
conciliant faut être cool
donc j'en vois que des signaux très
positifs apparemment des signaux de bons
gros naïfs
j'ouvre la valise il teste tout il
vérifie tout un parent c'est à dire
vraiment qu'elles sont par quels sont à
un moment donné j'ai un gros bloc notes
vous savez ce que j'utilise un spectacle
j'en ai un dans ce genre et ils font un
test anti drogue sur chaque page du bloc
notes on en est vraiment là parce que
j'aurais pu imbibé tout ça de drogue
mais ok pas de souci
et ils me demandent en même temps
d'allumer tous les appareils
électroniques en cas de contrôle c'est
normal ils vérifient que c'est pas une
bombe déguisés et c'est donc là où moi
je veux faire vite et montrer que je
suis de bonne foi je j'allume tout et je
tape bien les mots de passe devant eux
pour montrer que je n'ai rien à cacher
banon n'est pas toujours malin tout ça
ils vérifient bon ok c'est bon je range
d'orange mais chaque chose dans la
housse qui lui correspond parce que j'ai
des housses quand je voyage et je passe
à côté de la valise pendant qu'ils
finissent de fouiller la valise et moi
j'avais 300 l'équivalent de 300 euros en
cash
donc je leur montre aussi tu vois pour
pas qu'ils tombent dessus en dedans
c'est quoi ce cash mais c'est pas non
plus un incroyable donc tout va bien
et à la fin de tout ça il me demande de
me mettre contre le mur il sort qu'une
lampe torche dont je déconne ça il me
met contre le mur et ils me font juste
une fouille nana choquait pas de
problème après ils me disent ok c'est
bon tout et tout est bon mois l'avion va
pas tarder donc je remets tout vite fait
dans la valise je termine permettent les
300 euros exhibe iep et paf direction
l'avion 12 heures après me voilà en
france
je rentre chez moi guilleret à je suis
heureux de retrouver ma maison j'ouvre
ma valise d'abord je trouve mes 300 e
donc je le mets là j'ouvre la première
où ce qui conduit à un ordi et je vois
pas d'ordi est fatigué je sais pas je
percute pas je le fous sur le côté l'os
de l'ipad vite corps la hausse des
disques durs vite d'accord n'est
vraiment jusque là tout me paraît
extrêmement normal
je continue de vider toutes mes affaires
et un moment donné en fait j'ai un
déclencheur mental c'est je tombe sur le
chargeur de l'ordi et en en prenant le
chargeur je lis à ya un truc qui va très
vite dans la tête de se dire ah merde du
coup hop avec leur connerie j'ai mis
l'ordi en soute du coup il doit être
vite du coup faut que je le mette à
charger du coup là où c'est vide du coup
il est où
c'est vraiment ça qui s'est fait que je
vais non non non non non non non non non
non non non non j'ai commencé à tous
vides et partout il y avait rien et au
fond de moi je savais qu'il y avait rien
et là ça va très vite il faut comprendre
ce qui s'est passé et du cool enquête
elle est très simple à faire quelle
enquête cetud y attends je vais ouvrir
la valise y avait les 300 euros
c'est ce que j'ai remis un dernier si ça
avait été volée après que j'ai mis ces
300 euros ils n'y seraient pas donc
c'est forcément avant et le avant c'est
quand je suis avec les douaniers donc
c'est forcément là bas je veux dit est
ce que j'ai oublié de remettre dans la
housse et je me souviens vraiment à 22
d'être parti j'ai une image mentale de
me retourner et ce sont des grandes
pièces très austère vide
y'a rien à part une table en métal tu
vois donc je suis sûr d'avoir toutes
hormis je me dis ok y'a qu'une solution
en fait il y avait aucune raison de me
faire la palpation en fait au mieux je
me suis dit rapidement tu vas me dire en
quoi ils vont me faire la fameuse
fouilles intégrales et tout et puis ou
non ils ont juste tac tac tac - tu te
dis ok je pense que c'était vraiment
pour que je me retourne et les quatre
étaient mèche il peut tant que je me
suis retournée ils ont tout enlever des
housses et moi bah après quand je me
suis speed et parce que j'avais peur
d'oublier mon avion j'ai pas percuter
que le poids était beaucoup trop légers
toi tu tu remets tout et tak tak tu vois
et je me dis ouais mais attends ils
auraient pu faire griller si là je me
rends compte qu'il ya rien ils font quoi
les gros malin tu fais quoi gros malin
c'est des doigts n'y était pas dans ton
pays bas j'aurais dit lié pas et puis
peut-être il marie huawei on a regardé
quelque chose c'est bon on reprend le tu
vois il risque rien en soi
donc c'est une certitude ça s'est passé
à ce moment là et c'est une certitude
que tout le monde est complice à ce
moment-là je me dis bah ouais mais bon
comment je vais faire tu vois donc
j'appelle tout de suite l'ambassade de
france là bas et me disent ah oui
d'accord oui oui peut vous faites partie
de 2,3 qui ça arrive tous les jours à
l'aéroport de lima oui bien sûr cher oui
d'accord donc c'est connu c'est bien
c'est une expérience locale
du coup vous avez rien faire ben oui tu
m'étonne c'est très très bien et je vais
commencer à me débrouiller et en fait là
bas quand j'ai travaillé au chili et au
pérou
je travaillais avec un mec en local ça
fait beaucoup quand tu travailles dans
d'autres pays et que tu vas dans plein
de quartier tu travailles avec quelqu'un
qui bosse en local et qui te facilite un
peu la vie on va dire et ce mec là nous
facilitent tellement la vie
il est tellement à fond dans son taf il
a tellement envie de réussir à s'en
sortir que je pense vraiment que pour 10
euros ils dénoncent sa mère de ce que tu
veux quoi je me remets en contact vite
et avec lui je les écoute voilà j'ai
perdu mon toutou mon matos mais moi il
ya que lors des liens qui m'intéressait
ou disque dur de sauvegarde
donc si tu me le retrouve je te promets
je t'envoie 500 $ et je sais qu'il me
fait confiance et moi j'avais regardé un
peu les prix de revente au marché noir
de ce qu'on m'avait volé et la basse sur
place ça se revend pas plus de 300 donc
je me dis c'est un bon deal tu vois à
tous bon déjà lui même appel au bout de
24 heures pour me dire y'a rien tu leur
as pas études ici lui mme dia rien s'il
n'y a rien c'est sûr donc je dis ok
dernière carte
je vais contacter les douaniers la
douane sur place et l'aéroport et je
leur écris une lettre où je me dis
attendant ils peuvent pas avouer ça tu
vois c'est pas possible donc on est à +
48 heures en plus bon j'écris un super
mail au jeudi pour jour je m'appelle
fabien olicard j'ai été contrôlé c'est
bien normal avant de prendre mon avion
et j'ai oublié dans le local
l'ordinateur que sûrement vous n'aviez
pas vu puisque je les aime
derrière la porte et tu dis il faut que
je leur donne que des portes de sortie
de je ne vous accuse pas et vous n'êtes
pas appuyé zab la presse si vous dites
effectivement les à quoi tu vois même si
à 48 heures de passer et donc je prends
tout un truc à charge en mode je lis le
truc à la fin je dis donc je vient
d'avouer être un énorme débile mental
quand même parce que vraiment le mec n'a
fait attention à rien du tout et jordy a
évidemment si vous me le renvoyer en
compensation je saurai vous remercie en
vous envoyant la somme de judo mais de
500 $ pareil un truc comme ça quoi tu as
et donc la douane j'aurai une réponse
approximativement dans jamais jamais
jamais et l'aéroport de lima me dit non
non on n'a rien aux objets trouvés est
une [ __ ] et et à partir de ce moment
là c'est assez terrible on est à + 48
heures presque 72 heures et je me dis
bon va falloir reprendre g le corps de
ta vie qu'est ce qui est important
qu'est ce qui va te manquer qu'est-ce
qui va pas te manquer le plus important
c'est mon agenda
parce que j'ai toujours eu un rythme un
peu comme j'ai aujourd'hui j'étais
charge tout dans l'agenda est en fait
comme je venais de passer sur mac
quelques années avant j'avais tout
synchronisé avec le calendrier mac et
les contacts au mac
donc je n'ai pas perdu mon agenda et mes
contacts c'est un peu où fut pour moi
parce que ça veut dire je peux continuer
sans rien oublier
tout est noté tout est bon de ce côté là
tu dis ok ça c'est cool
ensuite au niveau de tout le reste
c'est-à-dire vidéos persos photos
personnelles travail documents textes
mes conférences mes recherches j'ai plus
rien ça c'est à dire que vraiment ma vie
reprend en 2011 à 0 de tout ce que j'ai
pu faire parce que comme je suis très
geek comme je te disais j'ai tout en
digital tout en numérique de moi et
j'avais juste mes sauvegardes locales
que j'ai emporté avec moi quand je
partais longtemps à l'étranger
alors là bas je commence à réfléchir à
la mettre un message sur facebook à
l'époque pour dire s'il y en a qui j'ai
envoyé des trucs de boulot de persos
hésitez pas à me les a renvoyées
hélas le petit plaisir de recevoir 200
réponses de et peuvent faire des
sauvegardes
c'est là où j'ai découvert la haine si
tu sait vraiment ce que t'as pas envie
d'entendre tu vois aujourd'hui oui je
suis sûr multiplie les sauvegardes tu
vois mais à l'époque maire ces
putschistes et coutumes et donc on me
renvoie pas grand chose et je regarde
l'agenda je me dis [ __ ] mais je vais
jamais m'en sortir parce qu'il me manque
toujours quelque chose
et à chaque fois que je vois qu'il me
manque quelque chose c'est comme un gros
coup de bambou sur la tête levée om et
non mais ça j'ai pu ça et ça j'ai pu ça
donc j'ai commencé à vivre au casif jour
le jour je regardais à plus trois jours
ce que j'avais à faire et là je me dis
ah ouais mais ça j'ai pu les notes de
conférences ok faugeron passagers
puissent info joie en fait j'ai tout
reconstruit comme ça petit à petit et
c'était très compliqué parce que je
perdais beaucoup de temps j'avais pu mon
ordi donc je travaillais sur l'ordi de
la fille avec qui j'étais à l'époque
mais c'était pas les mêmes logiciels et
tout et ça a duré un mois et durant tout
ce mois là je crois je m'en suis même
pas rendu compte je passais mon temps à
aller voir sur le hib et là bas de du
pérou et sur l'équivalent du bon coin là
bas des sites comme ça parce que déjà
c'était un clavier azerty la basse et du
quartile et en plus il avait des petites
rayures un peu un peu reconnaissables tu
vois et je me suis si je le vois je
l'achète je l'achète direct tu vois
c'est sûr peu importe le prix qu'ils le
vendent et puis au moins je vais
récupérer de la donner même s'ils ont
formaté je peux l'emmener dans un
magasin où ça coûte une blinde mais
après avec des ondes électromagnétiques
ils vont retrouver mes trucs tu vois et
donc je n'avançais pas en fait en
faisant ça je n'avançais pas du tout et
un moment donné j'avais besoin de faire
des fichiers et je me suis dit c'est
quand même con parce qu'il faut que je
rachète des programmes pour le mettre
dans son ordi alors que comme les mac
quand tu achètes un truc tu l'achète
pour toujours tu dois acheter un
matériel et ils seront télécharge pas au
bout d'un mois j'ai racheté un hacking
m'a fallu un mois pour me racheter un
ordi est aujourd'hui dans le contre coup
je me rends bien compte que tant que je
n'avais pas fait c'est parce que je me
mentais à moi-même tu vois je ne mettais
pas d'avoir tout perdu comme ça et et je
voulais pas passer à autre chose parce
que du jour je leur ai acheté un point
ça roulait quoi j ai plus jamais
vraiment repenser et cette histoire à la
une morale peut-être deux la première
c'est parce que c'est un douanier que tu
vas pas de faire enfler
et la deuxième c'est que la veille que
ça m'arrive je suffi au chili sur un
bateau de croisière où je travaille avec
un pote philippe roche et je lui fais
voir tout mon système d'organisation
numérique et je lui ai dit la phrase
suivante
ça c'est ma vie si je perds tout ça je
suis mort ça ça représente tout ce que
je suis et le lendemain la vie elle m'a
donné une leçon
elle m'a tout fait perdre et un mois
après j'ai su qu'en fait ma vie elle est
là elle et qui je suis allé ce que je
fais ce que je dis
ll dans les actes mal et surtout pas
dans le matériel et donc voila c'était
une belle leçon de vie je voulais vous
la raconter aujourd'hui
merci de m'avoir écouté
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]